[Applause]  Thank You mr. president this has been  truly the honor of the lifetime one of  the most incredible experiences anybody  could ever imagine and that's because  I've had the chance to be on the front  row of history and watch you drastically  change our country for the better you've  made America great you're going to  continue to make America great I  couldn't be prouder to be part of your  team I'm going to spend a little time  with my kids but no one will be a  stronger voice and more fierce advocate  for this president because he's fighting  for all of the people in this room and  for all of the people that you represent  all over the country and he's going to  have an incredible six more years to  make our country as strong as it's ever  been